shannon doherty's fight with stage four
cancers made her bond with sarah
michelle gellar
stronger than ever and only e.t sat down
with two best friends for a conversation
that will uplift your spirits
[Music]
so first of all i have to apologize that
entertainment tonight sent this
correspondent tonight um she's a little
unprofessional i'm
super disappointed i mean this is gonna
be rough
yeah let's see let's see how this goes
what's the most important thing that you
want people to know about you
oh um i'm gonna throw you a curveball
right at it i mean yeah you definitely
just just threw one right at me
um i don't know i think that like that
i'm
good i love it when people say you know
we're praying for you
and everything else but i'm doing better
than okay i'm doing well like
i feel strong and healthy and
confident and happy and is that why you
chose to share your diagnosis
i mean the original reason why i chose
to share the diagnosis was going to come
up
anyway and it is my story so i wanted to
come out with it but
since then the more that i share i also
want people to
not hear stage four cancer
and think of the person that going into
hospice and they can't work and
you get written off so quickly i'm able
to work a 16
18 hour day i'm not i don't think
anyone's watching i am not
able to do that it was february when
shannon went public with the devastating
news
her breast cancer had returned this time
it was stage four
and it spread to her spine leading up to
the announcement
shannon told her closest friends and
family during an intimate dinner
with her oncologist on hand to answer
questions
a lot of people have asked me questions
about the dinner is there anything you
want to say about that or
how you felt about that dinner well i
mean i knew
that particularly someone like you would
have more questions
and so for me to have my oncologist
be there so that he could answer the
questions to sort of squash any doubts
that people had or to comfort
i think it was just it was more to help
you guys yeah i mean i like to think i'm
an md but i think it stands for mom
doctor not actually
pretty sure it's not an actual md yes
okay a special correspondent my notes
say i'm supposed to talk about the
people in your life that have helped you
get through this time so i'm thinking
specifically they're asking about me but
it actually doesn't say that it actually
says specifically your mom and kurt
which i think has to be a misprint on my
part completely yeah i mean great how
have i been i'm kidding
uh but what all joking aside
do you appreciate that
how have you found the support from the
people around you you know obviously you
know how supportive that you've been
my mom has been a huge support my
husband um
and let's not forget about bowie who's
been like
the best dog ever people come up to me
all the time and they ask me about you
and
all i can think about is that effect
that you have
you know i went through brenda falling
in love
i'm sorry i just can't control myself
don't fight it
i actually literally did because i knew
you and i was your friend and so i see
the impact that that has on people and
so i'm so proud
how public you've been about it nobody
ever wants to see their friends suffer
but i think
more than that and i think this year has
been proof of that is that life is
short and vulnerable for all of us yes
and
we have to live each moment right i mean
we were talking about this earlier right
is that everybody's terminal
i might live a lot longer than somebody
who's perfectly healthy
you have no idea let's talk about stand
up to cancer just for a second here
because it is october which is breast
cancer awareness month so yes
so i'm an ambassador for stand up to
cancer and stand up to cancer
first off they're leading the charge in
research when somebody says to me like
oh do you think there's going to be a
cure i'm like
yeah yeah because of because of
an organization like stand up to cancer
and i think a lot of people ask me too
like how has the pandemic
affected you and the way i mean i know
the answer is it hasn't
right as you know i've been training for
this my entire life
uh i'm essentially shut in to begin with
plus this whole not having to do my
makeup except for like some mascara is
as a woman is amazing i mean it's genius
i
between the mask and then a baseball hat
sunglasses few
you could be me i could be you nobody
would know